What would Saint Patrick's Day be without green beer?
Here's how to make it with and without food dye.
You will need a light-colored beer, frosty beer mugs...
...and green food coloring or blue curacao liqueur.
Step one: Chill some 16-ounce beer mugs in the freezer.
Step two: When the glasses are nice and frosty,...
...add a few drops of green food coloring to the bottom of each.
Step three: If you'd prefer not to use food dye,...
...add a shot of blue curacao liqueur to each mug instead of the coloring.
Be sure to add the coloring or the liqueur before you pour the beer,...
...or else you'll have to stir it.
Step four: Pour light-colored ale into the chilled mugs,...
...since beer that's dark to start with will just get darker when dyed.
Add more food coloring if necessary.
Step five : Raise your glass and offer this traditional Irish blessing :...
..."May the road rise to meet you,..."
"...may the wind be always at your back. May the sun shine warm upon your face and rains fall soft upon your fields."
"Until we meet again, may God hold you in the hollow of his hand."
Did you know?
When Saint Patrick was 16 years old, pirates captured him in his native Wales...
...and sold him as a slave in Ireland.